hey guys it's Jenna here so today's
topic is something most of you have been
requesting for white rice when I
mentioned about white rice what is the
first thing that comes to your mind
but carbs been a huge weight gain
basically stay away from it white rice
is a staple food in the Asian diet just
like in some other cultures where bread
or potatoes are eaten on a daily basis
most Asians do eat white rice on a daily
basis be sure to watch this video
through because I want to let you know
why I ate white rice and why it is okay
to eat white rice so let's start with
some common facts we tend to hear about
brown rice versus white rice brown rice
is low English Simek index and white
rice is high in GI brown rice is high in
fiber and protein in comparison to white
rice brown rice takes much longer to
digest compared to white rice brown rice
is more nutrient dense than white rice
so are all these facts true well the
simple answer is yes they are all true
so why then would I want to eat white
rice instead of brown rice it's not as
simple as that
so I really want to break down each
point in more detail so let's start with
glycemic index the GI value of a food
basically informs you how quickly and
how high they raise your blood sugar
levels the higher the GI value of a food
is the quicker and higher it will raise
your blood sugar levels the lower the GI
value is the slower the food will be
digested and the lower it will raise
your blood sugar levels low GI food is
often linked to feeling fuller and
weight loss high GI food is often linked
to feeling hungry very quickly and
weight gain
so the glycemic index for one cup of
white rice is 66 where as brown rice
spent at 55
so should we simply look at the GI value
of a food and conclude whether or not
this food is healthy for you the answer
is known here's an important fact the GI
value of a food is determined when it's
eat
in isolation after an overnight fast
chances are you will not be eating a
huge bowl of white rice on its own first
thing in the morning in the Asian
culture white rice is often eaten in
moderation together with lots of
vegetables and also other healthy
sources of protein so the protein fat
and fiber in other foods will greatly
reduce the GI of the entire meal making
the high GI of white rice irrelevant so
you will still feel full and satisfied -
simply put when rice is eaten with other
foods whether or not is brown or white
rice it becomes irrelevant
so the second argument is that brown
rice is high in fiber and protein
compared to white rice so here's a quick
comparison between one cup of cooked
brown rice and white rice as you can see
there isn't a significant difference
between the nutritional values yes it is
important to have fiber and protein as
part of a balanced diet but having brown
rice will not significantly increase
your fiber and protein intake unless if
you were to eat a huge amount so it's
just irrelevant to think that having
brown rice over white rice will
contribute to your overall fiber and
protein intake you can still eat white
rice and meet your daily requirements by
adding lots of vegetables and healthy
protein into the meal for instance one
cup of cooked broccoli has a 5.3 gram of
fiber and raspberries has 8 gram of
fiber the next point is digestibility so
we have spoken about the speed of
digestion and how it's almost the same
now let's talk about your body's ability
to digest a food for most of you you
have no problem digesting where the
brown rice or white rice for some of you
including myself with digestive issues
eating brown rice on a regular basis can
cause constipation bloating gas diarrhea
and even cramps
just think of a brown rice like eating
the whole walnut without removing the
shell yes
there are nutrients on the shell but it
will cost your digestive system to work
a lot harder to break the shell hence
causing in digestion in
case white rice has gone through the
refinement process to remove the husk so
this is a better option if you have
digestive issues because white rice is
easier to digest you can also compare
between raw vegetables or cooked
vegetables to some of you eating raw
vegetables can cause in digestion so the
better option would be grouped
vegetables let's take a look at the
nutritional values especially the
micronutrients of brown and white rice
yup there is no argument that brown rice
it's definitely more nutrient dense than
white rice white rice is basically brown
rice with its outer layers removed and
those outer layers contain
micronutrients but it is very important
to note that those micronutrients will
not have a significant impact on weight
loss weight gain on muscle growth it
still comes down to your overall diet
and also lifestyle nowadays you can even
opt for enriched white rice which means
that they have added back some of the
micronutrients lost during the
refinement process so the question is
which is better white rice or brown rice
if you solely look at nutritional values
then of course the brown rice is the
winner if you look at the price tag
white rice is way cheaper and it has a
longer shelf life if you link it to
weight loss or weight gain choosing
between white rice or brown rice is just
irrelevant the bottom line is you can
choose to eat either brown rice or white
rice or mix them up choose the rice you
prefer and that is good to your
digestion white rice should not get a
bad rap I enjoy both brown rice and
white rice depending on where I am and
what goes with my meal and remember guys
the principle of an Asian diet is
moderation so you shouldn't be consuming
a huge plate of rice and then complain
about weight gain consumer eyes in
moderation with lots of vegetables and
also protein and you can even rotate
with other grains so which do you prefer
white or brown do let me know in the
comments below if you enjoyed this video
that
to give it a thumb up share it and do
subscribe to my youtube channel for new
weekly videos do also watch the recipe
videos right at the end all the best